Your brain right now, it's running 73
browser tabs. 14 are frozen. You don't
know where the music is coming from. And
one of them is mining cryptocurrency
without your permission. That mental fog
isn't laziness. It's cognitive overload.
Here's the kicker. Your brain treats
your unread emails like survival
threats. A full inbox triggers the same
neural panic button as a predator
chasing you. And it gets worse. After a
single distraction, it takes your brain
23 minutes to fully refocus. That quick
phone check. Congratulations, you just
lost half an hour. But here's what no
one tells you. While you sleep, your
brain cells shrink and fluid rushes
through like a power wash, clearing
mental garbage. Your mind isn't broken.
It's just dirty. And in this video,
you'll learn exactly how to clean it.
Not meditation apps. Actual neuroscience
that works.